140 years ago the calendar and urban
railway in the southwest of scotland set
up a rockfall detection system along
four miles of remote hillside railway
track the astonishing thing is
that system is still in operation today
140 years later and so far
no one's been able to come up with
anything better
the west highland lanes travel hundreds
of miles along natural mountainsides
there are different hazards depending on
where you are on this on the scottish
rail network through the fosun crew and
the hazards there are definitely rock
fall and boulder fall we're now at
bridge of orca on the west highland line
and the hazards here are much more
natural landslides and debris flows down
the steep sided mountains rocks that are
very small can pose at risk to the train
operations so something as small as a
microwave can cause a train a problem
something as big as a washing machine
could lead to derailment so it is a
really serious issue definitely stopping
the hazard at source is the best option
for us in a typical year we will spend
somewhere in the region of 40 million
pounds that's on things that prevent
landslides or improve the resilience of
our infrastructure to extreme weather
thank you very much
the scotland railway is about 3
500 track miles so we can't protect that
whole length so we need to look at other
ways of keeping the train safe which is
where the rockfall detection comes in
by modern standards it's a really basic
system there's no electricity just these
wires along the track held under tension
mechanically linked to the signals if a
big boulder falls down it hits a wire
the wire snaps the tension's released
and the signal at each end of that bit
of wire changes to show danger repeat
for 17 signals over the four miles of
railway the system was nicknamed
anderson's piano after its inventor and
after the humming noises that the wires
sometimes make in high winds anderson's
piano is a very old system 140 years
keeping something like that going in a
modern environment is quite challenging
firstly i guess there's the knowledge
there's not a user manual or a
downloadable book on how to maintain
anderson's piano we need to pass that
down through generations of technicians
and engineers and then there's just
getting hold of the kits a lot of it was
bespoke made in foundries in the
victorian era some of it we've had to
improvise some of it is just
availability materials so getting hold
of some of the wire can be quite
challenging and we think we've managed
to find a reasonable source that is a
good enough match the kind of rural and
fence that will use that kind of wire
the manufacturers are striving to make
it stronger and stronger and we don't
need it stronger for anderson's piano we
need it to break when there's a rock
comes through it it's not perfect
detection in terms of screening out so
vegetation can trip it off animal
movements if they do get inside the
boundary very manual to reset it's a
physical task that involves lifting
weights and repositioning
counterbalances and
manually moving signals back into place
so we can't do that when the trains are
running so that's disruptive to our
network it's a physical job that
involves human beings there's not a big
reset button that we can push the first
we know there's a problem is when the
signal goes up and normally the first
person to see that is the train driver
we're not able to respond someone to the
problem when it occurs we need to wait
until after it's occurred because the
first time we know about it's when a
driver tells us modern rail safety rules
mean that ideally no one should ever
drive a train past a signal that's set
to danger if that is ever needed because
of a fault somewhere it requires
checking and double checking with
central control if a train goes past a
danger signal without permission there's
always an investigation if it was
because the driver was negligent
it can end their career but the rules
for these signals have to be different
and they go against everything that a
modern train driver learns if these
signals are at danger you slow the train
down to walking pace to a speed where
you will be able to stop before you hit
any obstruction and you radiate into
central control but you do continue and
that would never be allowed on a new
system it's offering us a level of
protection so there's a there's a line
of defense there
that works
quite a lot of the time it would be less
safe without it prevention is better
than detection so stopping the rocks
falling is definitely better than
detecting them when they have occurred
so we put a great deal of effort into
containing some of the rocks on our
cuttings and then to catching boulders
through high strength high capacity
catch fences that are anchored into the
rock we employ all sorts of techniques
like netting and meshing and dowling to
hold all the rock in place we're
constantly looking for technology to
improve safety on the railway a
satellite technology that looks for
ground movement from space and does
change detection on that we've tried
listening fibres through fibre optic
cables that listen for an acoustic
signature of a rock falling or a tree
falling on the railway the cost of that
equipment is starting to come down we're
starting to see advances in technology
which is making it more affordable to
deploy but one of the big issues is
actually power these things will either
need a power supply which in remote
places can be hard to come by or they'll
run off batteries and solar panels which
need to have sufficient capacity to keep
them up all year round scottish winters
can be quite dark some of our trials
have been hampered by false alerts and
false alarms and too many false alerts
to run a railway at bridge of arcade
we've got some detectors in place to
capture any movement now they're the
wireless tilt meters that tell us if the
ground's moving like your spirit level
on your iphone that moves about
they will detect a bit of movement and
we will get an alert or an alarm
remotely from that we've then got a
camera on site that we can see the site
to see whether it's a false alarm or not
so we're not needlessly stopping trains
we've got some infrared kit on there so
that we can see at night time then for
red reflectors to see if there's been a
problem during the hours of darkness as
well it's all remote back to base and it
only requires a technician in our
control center to watch that and monitor
that it's also less prone to false
alarms and we can reset it at the touch
of a button so we know about it before
the train comes we can capture the
problem before it manifests itself on
the railway and then we can remotely
reset and remotely monitor it we do an
awful lot but it's not enough to go
everywhere and you know we can't
physically protect every mile of railway
it's just impracticable from talking to
the folks here i'd say that the best
description of these signals is that
they are a frustrating imperfect system
that's still better than nothing
backgrounds researching this video i
figured that there must be a better
solution and with all the confidence of
someone in the youtube comments who's
only watched half the video i thought
hey couldn't they just and
no
they can't at least not yet
how's that for timing
you